oh new game new game okay
uh let me switch the scene
maybe my opponent doesn't realize
there's a new game
okay so playing a low rate of player
get some timeouts
this happened to me earlier where I I
didn't realize the game started and I
only realized well I had about a minute
left
and then I still won so
assuming my opponent returns before they
flag
I'll have to still stay focused
I hope we get a game I want to try and
oh no my queen
yeah if E4 I'll go for Stafford because
there's like there's that one famous oh
no my queen trap
okay Stafford Gambit time
D3 Bishop G5 let's see it's uh it's not
happening
okay
H3 is one of the best moves
ah this is what uh Fabiano ran into no
Fabiano ran into something a little bit
different
maybe there's B6 here
but we're getting a similar structure
and queenies maybe Queen D6
okay
Castle
me back opponent offers a draw
no thanks
maybe King V8 to start
and this position requires uh aggressive
play
okay Queen C5 maybe take with a rook
some Rook lift potential there's another
idea to lift the other Rook as well
okay so Knight D5
it gets weird
I think it's okay though
and The Rook can't really retrieve so
it's committing itself to
being a fighter
I mean there's 94 here
now I can take
I'm still down upon but this is now weak
I think H4
wow C3 is a threat
almost in cc3
oh G5
and G5 looks playable
as if takes takes
I want to Checkmate on A1
unfortunately Queens don't move like
this
okay maybe H4 now
and positional play
I want to play Rook A4 and say oh no my
Rook but that just loses a rook
A5 is interesting
okay what to do
I think I should play H4
and just play positionally
try and win the pawn
okay rookie one Queen G7
I play this and this
tricky move
I could take
taken 9a5
if I take maybe B6 first
that's already tricky Maybe
this move first
to cover the back rank
oh oh no White's Rook
foreign
foreign
[Music]
there we go
thank you
I didn't want to clean trade but what to
do
this is a draw
oh no my oh no my queen opportunity
there's a funny Checkmate somewhere if
the king walks in juffar
okay going for B5
maybe I'll go for a rook chain it's
still a draw
no trade
okay it's still going for a book chain
component taking time
oh
foreign
yeah this is unnecessary
opponents got kind of low on time though
we're at move 143 oh that's kind of
funny
it's a long game I don't know
I don't want a flag
okay making some progress
foreign
there we go okay
oh I feel bad
I don't deserve to win this
okay
oh what to do
I mean over the course of the game
my opponent was like getting lower and
lower on time
um and there was like there were some
ideas I was trying to work out in the
pond versus pong
okay
oh we know my heart rate